je reviens tout juste d'agen où j'ai
élaboré où je cuisine et où je fabrique
des bars aux insectes
on nous avait prédit une alimentation en
capsule pour 2040 et bien dans désolé je
viens vous parler de bach aux insectes
alors figurez vous que je suis très
gourmand rien que d'y penser j'ai déjà
pas si j'aime beaucoup cuisiner ce que
je préfère se découvre de nouveaux plats
se découvrir de nouveaux mets et avoir
des feux d'artifice sur les papilles
c'est pour ça qu'en 2011 j'ai profité de
mon voyage d'études en chine pour partir
à la découverte de la gastronomie
régionale chinoise
alors ce que je préfère en voyage c'est
de suivre les locaux dans les marchés on
s'arrête au stand on s'en est bien là
vont tourner ne me fait pas peur à ce
que je mangeais des scorpions des
étoiles de mer et même des vers à soie
en brochettes
mais je n'avais pas assez alors j'ai
poursuivi mon parcours initiatique en
malaisie à bornéo où j'ai goûté le vert
de pamiers free dans la poêle et c'était
délicieux
un peu comme une amende caramélisées
mais j'en avais toujours pas assez
fallait bien rentrer en france mais
avant j'ai fait un petit crochet par la
thaïlande et j'ai remplacé les chips par
des insectes sauter à l'oignon
c'est très croustillant et la sauce est
à point
j'adorais m'en procurer sur les marchés
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
leur passe vraiment moment de partage ou
vérité et avec les ingrédients on peut
se rendre compte du climat de la
géographie d'un pays mais surtout lors
des façons manger et de cuisiner c'est
là où vous rencontrez vraiment les gens
l'ouverture au monde passe pour moi à
votre ventre par votre bouche par les
odeurs et par les textures et les
sensations en bouche
et dans l'autre côté j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être entrepreneuse j'ai toujours rêvé
de monter mon propre projet et puis j'ai
toujours rêvé de changer le monde et un
jour bingo je me suis rendu compte que
les plaisirs gustatifs que j'avais
rendre que j'avais ressenti avec les
insectes pouvait s'accompagner de mon
désir de changer le monde en effet ils
ont des apports nutritifs et
environnementaux exceptionnel du coup je
n'ai pas hésité une seconde ma mission
était claire je voulais transmettre ma
passion pour l'entomophagie c'est à dire
consommer ou devrais je dire déguster
des insectes comestibles
c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé mon entreprise
avec ma cousine elle aussi passionnée
d'art culinaire et le ddt et éthiques
et nous avons concocté des recettes
savoureuses délicieuse gourmand de bar
qui incorpore de la farine de grillons
parce qu'on est certaine que les
insectes doivent être cuisinés avant
d'être dégustés et c'est un objet de
gourmandise on doit avoir du plaisir à
manger des insectes et c'est pour ça
qu'en 2011
quand on s'est rendu compte quand on
était en chine
quand j'étais en chine que 80% des
habitants de la planète mange et déjà
des insectes depuis des millénaires sous
toutes leurs formes
salé sucré en galettes en gâteau tout ce
que vous voulez ça voulait dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous en occident nous
avions un terrain de jeu pour la cuisine
concrètement inexplorée pour des
passionnés comme ma cousine et moi juste
un rapide débriefing sur les apports
nutritionnels environnementaux des
insectes
donc on parle beaucoup de la protéine
les insectes est effectivement très
riche en protéines c'est vrai jusqu'à
trois fois plus que le boeuf mais c'est
pas tout c'est surtout très riche en
vitamines très riche en fibres et
surtout tu es riche en minéraux dont le
faire pour les femmes c'est excellent
mais aussi pour les enfants pour les
personnes âgées pour tout le monde
une implosion environnementale également
on en parle beaucoup c'est très très peu
consommateurs d'eau très très peu
consommateur de nourriture très peu
consommateurs des espaces et sané mais
quasiment aucun gaz à effet de serre
c'est pourquoi donc des fermes
fleurissent à travers toute l'europe à
travers toute l'amérique du nord et une
vraie filière économique se développe
aujourd'hui est d'ailleurs lé petit
grillon qui sont dans nos bars ou en
tout cas en farine dans nos bars ils
viennent de bourgogne et d'espagne et
ils sont nourris de légumes frais et de
céréales donc c'est bon tout va bien en
éthique alors ce n'est pas fini parce
que la france c'est le grand pays de la
gastronomie mondiale mais parfois elle a
eu de grandes difficultés à intégrer de
nouveaux aliments
je vous prends l'exemple de la pomme de
terre la pomme de terre a mis deux cent
cinquante ans à s'introduire en france
alors même qu'elle était déjà entrevu
dans les autres pays européens
c'est pourquoi antoine parmentier a une
idée de génie pour introduire la pomme
de terre en douceur dans la nourriture
parce que les paysans français
regardez d'un très mauvais oeil cette
plante qui pousse sous la terre dans le
domaine du dia plutôt que sous le ciel
comme les autres plantes
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a créé des
jardins à destination du roi où toutes
les pommes de terre seraient destinés au
roi et à sa famille donc il a mis des
soldats autour le jour en prenant bien
soin de retirer la garde la nuit pour
inciter au vol c'est pommes de terre si
précieuse et c'est cette manigance qui a
permis de faire rentrer petit à petit la
pomme de terre dans les moeurs d'eux
mêmes la tomate 250 ans à être
introduite au xviiie siècle parce qu'on
pensait que c'était une fleur empoisonné
et enfin le sushi mais là s'arrête sinon
je peux plus continuer j'ai trop faim
donc c'est pour ça que je suis anti m'en
persuader que si aujourd'hui nous ne
mangeons pas des insectes
quotidiennement c'est loin d'être
irrémédiable et que très prochainement
on n'en mangera sont toutes leurs formes
en entier dans des pizzas dans des
crêpes dans des salades ou en farine
dans des quêtes des soupes des gâteaux
et d'ailleurs ça me fait penser puisque
je reviens d'agen à côté de moi il y
avait quelqu'un qui lisait un article
vous avez sûrement lu comment jour nous
en 2045
je n'ai pas pu résister je lui ai donné
une barre et il s'est lancé avec moi
dans un voyage vers le futur qui avait
grand plaisir il en redemande et soudain
j'ai réalisé si les voyages à travers le
monde ne suffisait pas pourquoi ne pas
voyager dans le futur aussi c'est
pourquoi que je propose de manger le
futur avec moi aujourd'hui
merci